here's what I don't like about the new
movie mortal instruments city of bones
the fact that it's about a clash between
preppy angels and demons the fact that
it forces me to use the phrase urban
fantasy and the punctuation mark in the
title here's what almost every modern
movie title consists of the name of the
overarching property then a colon and
then the name of the specific episode of
the series this acute colon itís does
many things to me it gives me
indigestion it fills me with fury it
forces me to adopt a facial expression
that looks like a colon followed by an
open bracket but it also makes me
question the legacy of Star Wars even
more than Jar Jar Binks did because Star
Wars is the root cause of many things
including excessive marketing tions the
mainstreaming of the science fiction
genre the resurgence of the white as a
scene transition technique and worst of
all the cult of the trilogy nowadays
every Hollywood producer an author of
young adult fiction seems to think that
their stories simply can't be contained
in one movie or one book there's a word
for this greed I don't care where this
trend came from semicolon I just implore
the perpetrators to please stop
immediately ! we'd all really appreciate
it clearly oh hell did I live the coffee
machine on
? what do you think is the most
ludicrous movie title let me know in the
comments